kanto bristol from poland
let's go with an e4 and well um
we're basically
well that's that's sweet i i appreciate
it
well you're part of the reason very few
people do okay so
oh next level we're facing macarocon
how dare he play something that i play
with luck
okay so what do we do against the car
con if we want to play we want to play a
sharp line
we can play the narrow con we can play
the
con so okay so we're going to go d4
we're not going to play the naruhan i'll
show you what that is
um but the classic way of um
of getting this into a sharp position
the traditional old-school way
is to go for the panov attack and the
pawn of attack is to take on d5 this is
the exchange car oh this is a gateway to
very peaceful lines
but the game but the way to make this
very interesting and tactical
not to suggest that the exchange with
bishop d3 which is the main exchange is
not interesting it's a great line
it's not that tactical though boom c4
immediately contesting the center
this should make sense right you're
trying to get rid of this fun
and you're developing your pieces with
an eye toward pressuring the spawn he
takes it okay so he relents
and now this leads to one of the most
well studied
and most famous structures of all time
the iqp
the isolated queen pawn structure why is
it called that well because there's a
pawn on d4 and it is isolated what does
that what does that mean
means there are no neighboring pawns
right there's no pawn on c2 there's no
pawn on e2 we've given both of them up
and a lot of people approach this from
the perspective of is the iqp
good or bad and if there was an answer
to that then this wouldn't be so well
studied
the iqp whether the iqp is good or bad
depends entirely on the circumstances it
is
neither good nor bad it and that's the
magic of it is it depends entirely on
on what else is going on in the position
it can be it can be the reason you win
the game it can be the reason you lose
the game
it was the winter of despair it was the
summer of
butcher the dickens quote he he just
um chatted me move okay he
he just um chatted me move
okay so we shall move yes queen b3 is
okay so bishop f5 is a mistake
uh they get to have grisha for the tier
one this is a classic fork i mean you
guys are most a lot of you're familiar
with this idea
it's just a fork it's a fork against two
pawns and we're gonna take this one
thank you
yeah knight bd7 and we shouldn't go
crazy like this is the moment when a lot
of people go off a cliff and they're
like i'm going to
mess him up i'm going to knight b5 and
i'm going to stick my knight into c7
you need to be careful here because we
haven't completed our development
particularly our kingside development
and
oh he will regret this and so let's
instead of doing anything a rash let's
focus on completing our development
mindfully
we can go bishop f4 to prevent
um to prevent him from going rook b8
that's possible he's not threatening
rook well he's not really threatening
rook b8 because
well because we're going to take the
pawn on a7 so what's the simplest
developing move what's the most
meat and potatoes developing but i'm
going to literally think this out just
to annoy him
no just kidding
okay don't do that and i have some
stories but he does go rook be it so
obviously when we look at this carefully
and what you got to be careful about is
that your queen doesn't get like trapped
in a repetition
like he keeps chasing the queen and he's
actually close to that it's kind of
funny that he's
he's he's actually well the thing is
i'm actually have to calculate this
sorry i'm thinking
because he's this is a funny paradox
where he's probably not
seen half of this but there's a crazy
line i just calculated which i'll show
you after the game
i think we can take the pawn i think
we're safe to take the pawn
and the alternative would have been to
go to a6 which would have been the safer
option that was just fine
but i think we're good i think he's not
going to repeat moves
and i'm not trying to do this to be
fancy i'm just honestly trying to make
sure he's not going to make a draw
by repeating moves and attacking the
queen permanently
and again assuming now what was i
calculating
i was calculating to move rook to a8
continuing to harass the queen
i assume that he he's going if i'm
getting the right read on him i think
he's probably going to do that
um but what he should do he goes rook
before okay so he goes
for the bishop which is not scary at all
because this bishop can be easily moved
and not only can it be moved it can be
moved in a way
that makes him regret his previous move
because this rook on v4 is
really misplaced now i a lot of you have
the instinct to move back which is
understandable
but let's think about all of the squares
available to us and if we do that we say
oh wait a second i have this b5 square
it's a great square
protected by the knight it's not amazing
the fact that it's only protected by one
piece what is amazing
a the fact that we're pinning his knight
to his king and he's not even developed
yet and b
look at this rook how are you getting
back good
sir um well you're not and we're
threatening a3 that's basically going to
trap the rook he's going to have one
more square
but that's a ticking time bomb there
now if you really want to play five head
moves if you really want to play five
head moves
a3 is not even obligatory
although we're gonna play this very
simple as i i've said today way too many
times meat and potatoes let's go a3
and i'll show you after the game let me
write this down just
so i don't forget there is a nice move
instead of this too
okay but should be eight makes sense
okay um again it's a surface level
threat
totally understandable why he played it
and we can move our queen to a variety
of places it doesn't
particularly matter queen b7 is fine i
mean
i wouldn't move the well actually
perhaps it's good to move the queen
yeah it's a great move actually i i
didn't give it the benefit of the doubt
initially queen b7 is actually amazing
because it pins the rook so remember
that pins are are two-sided
street um when you move your queen to b7
it may seem
like you are pinning yourself but you're
also pinning the rook
a piece of higher value can x-ray a
piece of lower value
and that's important here because the
rook is going to be unfortunate if it
goes to b3
it's going to be undefended what does
that tell us well then we can take the
knight with check
we can expose the uh the attack on the
rook
yeah but queen takes d7 is bad because
remember his knight is defended by the
other knight so that would blunder the
queen
and bishop takes d7 would be ineffective
for a similar reason it would actually
open up the gates for his rook to come
back
we don't want that we want the gates to
be closed so if if i were black here i
would take the bishop
at the very least he should try to get
something for his rook otherwise he's
going to lose a full rook
well if he castles we're remember we're
attacking his rook
he's welcome to castle but we're going
to take his rook
and queen c5 i liked i actually was
going to propose it but
but it's spicy but he goes rook b3 and
then we have to do additional work to
trap his rook which would be fine
and we shouldn't necessarily play games
with a queen like that i mean
okay he goes rook b3 and as you guys can
see we can take the knight let's check
we're not blundering our queen that's
check check supersedes that
and we can take his rook and now the
game is basically over
his queen side is no more thank you and
prof dw
is now a sub which is even more
important
yeah so now let's castle let's complete
our development
okay
so he's building up a battery on h2 he's
actually playing quite well i have to
say he's
he's making good moves but uh let's not
toy with this battery that's a serious
battery here let's not
let's not play games so what's the
simplest way to not play games
what does that mean
how can we avoid the games yeah let's
just go g3 now i understand that that's
a bit weakening
because it is weakening right we are
weakening the light squares in fact
we're allowing a move like this
but we are up a rook and he's got no
pieces on the king side other than the
bishop to inflict any kind of
serious damage there's no it's not like
he's got his queen on the king's side
and
he's going to lobster pincer checkmates
that's not what's happening here
and we're also yes so the the other
important thing is we're preparing
bishop f4
so this is this comes back to something
i called one of the most overrated rules
which is not to push pawns in front of
your king
it's a good rule it's a good rule of
thumb but it needs to be taken in
moderation moves like h3 or g3 are often
less weakening than they seem
particularly when you're trying to
achieve a very important goal
you can't do one thing without making
some concessions
and i think that this is a good example
of that right
okay
if i was like seven years younger i
would like type
move to him but there's no no need for
that
yeah i mean it's not essential to make
luft but it's not bad
i don't mind it
if i was like 16 in high school i'd
totally do that but
sometimes taking the higher road is good
particularly because
i'm the one smurfing here okay
yeah luft is um okay bishop g4 good move
again attacking the knight
he's making a lot of good moves and a
lot of good threats
so again good idea not to immediately
assume we should move the knight we need
to
consider what else we can do and if we
simply open up the possibility of
not moving the knight but instead doing
bishop f4 right the movie prepared
attacking his queen
getting our last piece out and we're
well on the way
to victory here
okay so
yeah i can totally totally do that
yeah i yeah like i went to
phil's and then i went to kale kale
express this morning
in san fran and it was awesome so let's
go to 85 let's just start trading
everything
let's start trading everything
okay yeah this is just this is just over
i mean we're up a rook
he's got some some threats here that
need to be
that need to be watched for but largely
it is
it is it is completely winning
yeah no more iqp by the way yeah that's
a good point all right that's our iqb
has lived out its life
it's retired to the beaches of
i don't know it's retired to the
seychelles and it's it's enjoying
good life now on e5 thank you evarde pfr
for the tier one and um
yeah yeah we are playing a gm
yeah well i have to get the permission
from chess.com so they can go back
through my games and
refund the ratings but um
you know yeah but i'm not actually i
mean you don't technically need the
permit i mean i think i can open a
second account i'm not i'm not forbidden
from doing that
so i don't think that you you need to
declare there's no rule that you need to
declare your title
um i don't think that's a rule that's
written one could argue that it's
dirty to do this but i also think people
shouldn't make too big of a deal
out of out of it i mean of course it's
easy for me to say that
but it's also just objectively not a big
deal this doesn't happen
so many times to people that oh i played
another i played another one of those
gm's today oh my god they're like
yeah i know they're killing me like i
can't log into chess.com without meeting
these
hordes of gm smurfing on the 10-minute
pool
okay
so he's putting the bishop on f3
and the thing is the thing is
this is actually a delicate situation
why because if he puts his queen on h3
right now
we're going to lose he's going to
lobster pincer made us on g2
and that can be a little bit as
concerning so we need to deal with his
bishop how do we deal with it
well some of you may notice the x-ray
that we have over the bishop so
there's an impulse immediately to move
this knight away
and there's an impulse to move the
knight forward right we want to move it
forward but think about it this way the
knight on b5 is that night really
serving the purpose
of defending the king and that's as we
could understand the key
uh here is to is to you know all hands
on deck
all hands on deck so if you think about
where this knight could go instead
we could drop it back to e2 that looks
like an ugly move it looks very
unappealing but
we could actually bring it over to f4
what would that do
well his queen is limited in the squares
that it could go to to keep the bishop
protected and queen g4 is the only
logical square but then after knight f4
we're controlling the square that his
queen wants to go to
and we actually want to play h3
ourselves and knock the queen away from
his defense over the ship and this
actually is another byproduct
he simply takes which makes our job so
much easier now
we no longer have the bishop to worry
about our king is perfectly safe and we
can just start pushing
the pawn and winning the game
immediately okay
yeah let's take the pawn actually and we
can
you know the lord has come for our iqp
but now we're going to come for black's
king very shortly
thereafter and let's go okay so we're
also going to come after black's queen
and he's going to resign
good game good game for sure nice when
you were never in trouble good to know
okay other than when you told us to move
now
the pawn of again when i'm talking about
these opening variations
you shouldn't be thinking good and bad
you should be thinking more okay these
are the kinds of positions that these
typically lead to
uh yeah uh and bishop d3 is
is the exchange car oh that's a great
line you basically build up a little bit
of a pawn chain
then you develop your pieces normally
and it's a pretty peaceful line and it's
actually
the recommendation of some books like
why this is one of white's best chances
to get an edge
and um a lot of gm's play but the pawn
off
is very um very old line
and let's see when it was first played i
actually have a book on
pawn off pawn knob was a very obscure i
mean
very i assume few people will know who
khan was i've heard of the player pawn
off
in a context other than the pawn of kara
khan
there it is i found it it's very
stubborn
just hiding but i found it um
so i told you guys about this so in in
soviet russian in the 1980s
in the 70s there was a series called the
you know black book series and this is
because the the covers were
dark black and then there was the just
the chasse player on it and it basically
was dedicated to
all these soviet players were not very
well known but their best games were
annotated
and um and it was they were annotated by
top grand masters they were commissioned
to annotate the games
to raise awareness of more obscure
players
um and these were phenomenal books
they're hard to get and
i have most of them and there was one on
pawn up so this is this says vasily
panov
and that's that's what he looked like
not someone you probably wanted to piss
off at the chess board it just seemed
like he's
about to complain to the arbiter about
his opponent like
wiping his nose too much but yeah
anyways um
i shouldn't be picking on on good old
pawn off
yeah so vaseline pawn off he died he was
born
1906 and died in 1973
biography lots of pictures him giving a
simul
and obviously his like objective
greatest contribution
was the pawn off and there's these young
pawn off here
that's young that's young pun off okay
not that anybody care like i'm showing
the young
panop looked like when he was 20 but you
can kind of see
yeah he i feel like he had that face all
the time okay
so he yeah
well you know um he hadn't invented the
pawn up yet so he was
he was not happy he was not fulfilled
until we met the plan off
yeah no no definitely he's got the
he's got that look um but the pawn of
itself was first played in the year
his first plane of the year 1844 wow
long time ago long before panav was born
so it's been around and as always is the
case
the guy whom the opening was named after
is
rarely an alekhine played it like a
million times panopt did play it a
couple times
but it's it's very murky how these
openings get named
and it also could have been that he
wrote an article on
on on this opening in some journal and
it got
it basically what the equivalent of
going viral in like the 50s
so it's it's sort of hard to
fully describe okay so in the pawn of
okay dc is not
bad but it's not great he should just
develop
and i'm not i'm just i'm a little bit
i'm fried so i'm not gonna go
full deep into like the iqp positions
but i will do that probably tomorrow
but the bottom line is that by taking on
c4 he is helping me develop
and this square that i've highlighted in
it in red
is crucial because the person who's
gotten this is the
shortest and the easiest way to
understand who's better in an iqp
position
is to look at who has control of the
square in front of the pawn
if white has control of the square in
front of the iqp pawn white's generally
going to be good
if black is blockading the square in
front of the iqp pawn generally with his
knight
oftentimes black will be in good shape
and
that is a very cheap like cheap and and
unnuanced way of looking but
if if you need like an emergency way of
evaluating an iqp position you should do
that
okay but bishop f5 is bad for
reasons that have nothing to do with the
iqp uh
but rather reasons that have to do with
these two pawns being very weak
and uh we win one of them so i want to
go straight to the moment where i was
talking about
now isolated queen's pawn iqp is an
abbreviation
if he kept harassing the queen how would
we have evacuated
this on sort of annoying predicament
well what we would have done
is we would have gone to c6 and he
continues to harass he can go rook b6
then we go to a4 then he can go to b4
this looks like a fork
when i needed to calculate queen a6 he
can go to b6 and he continues to harass
us
but we can drop the queen to a5 what's
the point
of this well the point of this is to
lure him into going bishop before then
when we get to queen a4
he can't put his rook on before any
longer our queen is finally safe
and i think white is better here so this
weird sort of confusing line is what i
was trying to calculate making sure that
our queen actually had a
series of of moves to worm its way out
of the cage
um it's a cool line yeah it's a cool
line you're just nothing special about
it just getting your queen out
but the other thing that i wanted to
mention in this position what would have
been the other way to get to the rook
we could have played the move knight e5
that puts pressure on the knight on d7
which is good
and it encourages him to castle it just
occurred to me that this actually
blunders the knight
but my main idea was to go knight c6
here and to fork but this is all crap
because
he should take the knight with his
bishop but the bottom line was we're
getting rid of his good bishop
which is sort of um a
you know kind of an important um
an important piece that is holding his
position together like a glue glue piece
no a 1200 is not going to calculate that
but that's what you don't need to you
don't need to calculate this
you can sort of do things intuitively so
queen b7 was the key move right queen b
so queen c5
a lot of you guys are mentioned because
it actually also stops him from castling
but the move rook takes b5 and response
is annoying because we can't take with
the knight that's a very common mistake
it's
not being attentive to how things have
changed
we no longer have the bishop so guess
what the queen is not
pinned and knight is not been anymore
the queen is lost
so we have to take with a queen and then
he can castle and it
it's turned out that we made a lot of
moves with our queen whereas after queen
well after queen b7 rook b5 we actually
can take with our knight
maybe that's not even that much better
than taking with the queen but i guess
at least it's an option
and the rest after we took was very
straightforward i i can delve into it
maybe later but
i think that i'm i'm at i'm right about
at the finish finish line
for today so um i
really appreciate this community and uh
we'll keep on
keep on keeping on okay
[Music]